My name is Collen Gwiyo. I'm from Zimbabwe.
I'm a member of the young global leaders and
I'm a member of parliament in Zimbabwe. My
view is that it's true. The coming of the
World Cup next year will greatly benefit the
continent in three respects. Firstly, definitely
South Africa will have an advantage, but also
the region, second, will also benefit the
neighboring countries depending on the level
of preparedness. And also the different countries
within the continent. As long as they have
already put in a place a program for that
tourists who will be coming to see the World
Cup will also spend extra days in the different
countries, so that they can experience different
African cultures. And also the areas of food,
special interests. It is my hope that the
countries should also gain their position
to put in place mechanisms to fit themselves
after the World Cup. Of course there will
be a need to continue with issues of economic
development having found the bases from the
investment arising from the World Cup. Thank
you.